>>> MORE NOW ON THOSE IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTS ON THE
INVESTIGATNS INTO JANUARY 6th
THAT WE MENTIONED AT THE T OF
THE BROADCAST, THE FIRST SOURCES
TELLING CNN THAT SECRET SERVICE
MADE DISABLED TEXT MESSAGES ALL
FROM WHAT HAS TURNED INTO A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION TO HAVE
PERIOD SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th
WERE DELETED DESPITE BEING
REQUESTED BY INVESTIGATORS.
THE SECRET SERVICE DECLINED TO
COMMENT.
THE DEVELOPMENT COMES AFTER
SIGNIFICANT ESCALATION OF THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION AS WELL.
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT THE MAN LIZ
CHENEY SAID TRIED TO DO WHAT WAS
RIGHT, PAT CIPOLLONE, HAS BEEN
SUBPOENAED BY A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY.
WHAT'S MORE, SOURCES TELL CNN
THE DEPUTY WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
PATRICK PHILBIN HAS BEEN
SUBPOENAED.
BOTH MEN HAVE TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
JEFFREY TOOBIN.
WOULD PAT CIPOLLONE SAY MORE TO
A FEDERAL GRAND JURY THAN HE
WOULD TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE?
>> HE WOULD HAVE TO BE FORCED TO
BECAUSE HE OBVIOUSLY MADE A
CERTAIN SET OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
HE WOULD TALK ABOUT CERTAIN
THINGS BUT NOT OTHERS TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
BUT THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS WILL
WANT TO KNOW MORE, ESPECIALLY
ABOUT HIS CONVERSATIONS WITH
TRUMP BECAUSE AFTER ALL,
REMEMBER, DONALD TRUMP IS
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T TEXT, WHO
DOESN'T USE EMAIL.
SO, THE ONLY WAY TO DETERMINE
HIS INTENT, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A
CENTRAL ISSUE IN THIS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, IS THROUGH THE
TESTIMONY OF THE PEOPLE SPEAKING
WITH HIM.
>> I KNOW WE'VE ENDLESSLY TALKED
ABOUT THESE EXEC TIFF CLAIM
PRIVILEGES, SOME OF THEM PHONY,
SOME OF THEM NOT.
HOW DOES THAT GET ADJUDICATED?
WHO DECIDES?
>> IT WILL GO THROUGH THE
COURTS.
IT'S NOT JUST EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE HERE.
IT'S ALSO ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S A GOVERNMENT
LAWYER, THE COURTS HAVE HELD
THERE ARE CERTAIN ASPECT WAS
OATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE THAT
ATTACH WHEN IT'S A GOVERNMENT
LAWYER.
SO, IT'S ACTUALLY A SERIOUS
COMPLICATED LEGAL ISSUE ABOUT
WHAT HE CAN TESTIFY ABOUT.
THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE OF CRIME
FRAUD EXCEPTION WHICH WOULD
ALLOW HIM TO TESTIFY.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO GO
TO THE COURTS.
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY
WAS REALLY RUNNING OUT OF TIME
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE DONE
BY ELECTION DAY.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS A LITTLE
BIT LONGER.
BUT THIS COULD TAKE MONTHS ZBLMT
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ON THIS,
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IS ON THIS.
IT SEEMS THEY HAVE BEEN CALLING
PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A REALLY BIG
DEAL, THE CHANGE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION.
REMEMBER, THERE WAS CRITICISM
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS SIMPLY
PROSECUTING THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
TRESPASSING IN THE CAPITOL.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE.
BUT ESSENTIALLY ALL LOW LEVEL
PEOPLE.
NOW IT'S 100% CLEAR THAT THIS IS
AN INVESTIGATION INSIDE THE OVAL
OFFICE OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHETHER THAT LEADS TO AN
INDICTMENT, I CERTAINLY DOUBT
THAT.
>> DO THEY HAVE ENOUGH PERSONNEL
FOR THIS?
I KNOW GARLAND SAID THIS IS THE
BIGGEST THING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS EVER DONE.
>> IT'S REALLY JUST AN AMAZING
DEMAND ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THEY HAVE BROUGHT PROSECUTORS IN
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALMOST A
THOUSAND CASES JUST AT THE
CAPITOL ALONE, BRINGING IN THE
GRAND JURY WHEN THERE'S A
PANDEMIC AND PEOPLE CAN'T SIT
NEXT TO EACH OTHER IN
CIRCUMSTANCES, IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING.
BUT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
DONE AN AMAZING JOB WITH THE
CAPITOL RIOTERS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> THE SECRET SERVICE TEXT
MESSAGE THING.
NOW THE SECRET SERVICE SAYS THEY
MAY DISABLE TEXT MESSAGING ON
EMPLOYEES' PHONES.
TWO SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
MATTER ARE SAYING THAT.
DOES IT MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU
THAT THIS IS ALL UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THE HOMELAND
SECURITY DEPARTMENT.
THE HOMELAND SECURITY DEPARTMENT
WOULDN'T KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
TEXT MESSAGES FROM JANUARY 6th I
FIND TERRIFYING.
>> THE KEY QUESTION ON THIS
WHOLE TEXT MESSAGE INVESTIGATION
IS INCOMPETENCE OR MALEVOLENCE.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE SECRET SERVICE IS TRYING
TO MAKE THE CASE, PLEASE,
PLEASE, WE'RE INCOMPETENT.
WE CAN'T EVEN ALLOW OUR AGENTS
TO TEXT MESSAGE IN 2022 BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW HOW OUR SYSTEM
WORKS.
THAT'S A PRETTY APPALLING
THOUGHT.
BUT IT IS NOT AN EXAMPLE OF
PEOPLE INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
DESTROY EVIDENCE.
>> RIGHT